el agua les llegaba a la altura del
cuello los pasajeros atrapados en el
suburbano y algunos se despedían ya de
sus familiares a través del móvil dirían
después que lo más angustioso ni
siquiera era el agua sino que el vagón
se estaba quedando sin aire es una de
las escenas más dramáticas de las
inundaciones que están afectando estos
días a change show la capital de general
en el centro de china en tres días ha
caído la misma lluvia que en un año por
ponerlo en un contexto en la ciudad
alemana de colonia donde la semana
pasada murieron 20 personas por las
inundaciones cayeron 150 milímetros en
un día en junio han caído 200 milímetros
en apenas una hora hay 200.000 personas
en refugios y el miedo ahora se
concentra en las presas y los embalses
que corren peligro de colapsar en
cualquier momento china ha declarado el
estado de guerra y enviado tanto a
militares como personal de rescate
renán es uno de los nudos fluviales más
importantes de china porque por ahí pasa
el agua que es trasladada desde las
provincias húmedas del sur hasta las
provincias más
del norte las lluvias no son raras en
esta temporada pero las de este año han
desbordado los pronósticos más
pesimistas